tonight we're going to tell you about
two different illegal immigration
stories from two different states both
demonstrate how politicians are putting
Americans health and well-being at risk
now this is not hyperbole the
ramifications if this is not addressed
are very serious perhaps deadly serious
first in California a sanctuary state we
get a glimpse of what type of America we
have to look forward to if Democrats
take back the White House in 2020 scarce
resources are being lavished on the
growing number of illegal immigrants in
that state while the situation gets more
dire by the day for California's
homeless population now it's so bad that
normally sang wouldn't people like dr.
Drew Pinsky an LA resident himself are
issuing themselves dire warnings
tuberculosis is exploding Rodan born we
were one of the only major cities in the
country does not have a rodent control
program and sanitation has broken down
we had a typhus outbreak last number we
will have a typhus outbreak this summer
I'm hearing from experts that bubonic
plague is likely it's already here the
entire population is at risk
disgustingly negligent it's almost like
I thought I was driving overnight I
thought do they want the people on the
streets to die is that is that really
there they don't care if they all die
where we are now beyond negligent and in
april kaiser Health News reported that
deaths in the homeless population just
in Los Angeles County alone jumped 76
percent in the past five years more than
900 died last year alone now how can
this be allowed to happen when millions
of illegals in the state enjoy not only
legal sanctuary but also the right to
apply for things like in-state tuition
driver's licenses and state funded of
course healthcare for their children
then over the weekend we learned that
California has gone from sanctuary state
for dreamers
- just being a sucker state for
Americans a just announced state budget
deal will now give healthcare benefits
to many adult illegals - those between
the ages of 19 and 25 will now be
eligible for California's Medicaid
program known as medical every person
should have access to quality affordable
health care our away judges and
politicians may turn back our progress
but we will never waver in our pursuit
of guaranteed health care for all
Californians well he said it do it and
they're doing it the price tag is
estimated to be 98 million bucks
annually I think those homeless people
including homeless vets might be able to
use that money but remember 98 million
since the Democrats did the math the
real cost is probably I don't know
double or triple remember what they
estimated that ill-fated bullet train
would cost you know and how they would
pay for that well how they're gonna pay
for this by the way by taxing citizens
who don't have health insurance
in other words reviving the penalty of
Obamacare remember that now even
liberals in the state of California seem
to be at a breaking point just a few
months back singer and performer cher
who considers bashing Trump a moral
imperative sounded off herself saying in
a tweet I understand helping struggling
immigrants but my city Los Angeles isn't
taking care of its own what about the
50,000 plus citizens who live on the
streets people who live below the
poverty line and hungry if my state
can't take care of its own
many are vets how can it take care of
more I never thought I'd agree with cher
but I agree with Sharron now most of the
reporting on California's new health
care giveaway to illegals is is framed
this way and I love this it's framed as
the Golden State sending a message to
the Trump administration or California's
effort to distance itself from Trump but
the better framing the more accurate
framing would be California
with its high taxes homelessness problem
and we're legal aliens are treated
better than poor veterans is giving
America a blueprint of how not to
proceed policy wise yet despite this
disastrous state of affairs Democrats
are rushing to embrace these California
values I think that anyone who is in a
situation I'm opposed to any policy that
would deny in our country any human
being from access to public safety
public education or public health period
and that's not all Bernie Sanders would
also guarantee the health care costs of
everyone residing in the u.s. illegal or
not so just a review if spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on
health care over years for illegal
immigrants requires eliminating funds
that could be used to assist American
citizens living in California just focus
on California those people who are in
need well so be it that's just what you
have to do and by the way California
isn't alone in the state of Texas
they're suffering from a lack of
congressional leadership well the
president struggles to deal with an
overrun border Congress is trying to
block his every effort refusing to
reform Asylum laws to protect our
citizens now did you know that in the
month of May Border Patrol arrested more
than a hundred and thirty two thousand
people trying to crash our border and in
the first two weeks of June more than
500 Africans have been arrested trying
to sneak into the country as well that's
kind of new now hundreds of illegals
from the Congo apparently are applying
for asylum and being deposited in San
Antonio now this could clearly be a
public health concern why
well according to Reuters the number of
cases of Ebola and eastern Congo has
passed too
thousand government figure showed as the
rate of new cases tripled and
containment efforts faltered in the
remote unstable region now the city of
San Antonio got back to the Ingraham
angle tonight and said for them Ebola
they don't believe is a concern why well
they say the incubation period is 21
days for that disease and that they
believe these folks have been outside
their country for six to seven months
but I don't know why would we even put
that to chance and I I'm not sure we're
really tracking the travel patterns of
everybody coming into the country but
they're telling us don't worry tonight
it's okay and remember under current law
these asylum seekers must be processed
and then released into the mainland
United States last week the San Antonio
Department of Human Services sent out an
urgent message for French speakers to
help translate for the Congolese
families now housed in a city run
shelter but one wonders where's the
concern for the health of the San
Antonio citizenry and frankly citizens
across the United States and who's going
to translate their concerns to federal
officials in why is no one questioning
the pressure that this will place on
communities across the country that are
now obligated to house educate and feed
people from other continents when we
seem incapable in some cases of caring
for our own citizens and that's the
angle